jean-claude j'aimerais maintenant tu
m'avais c'est toi qui m'a proposé de
faire ce qu'on appelle un pool contact
ok pour le contact c'est très simple on
va jouer avec des cartes
celui qui aura la carte la plus faible
devra se casser des oeufs de plus en
plus gros sur la tête alors jean-claude
il désignera à chaque fois un
chroniqueur quand il perd quand il à
perdre
il devra se le cacher sur la tête
d'accor merci jean claude en tout cas
d'être avec ses 2
c'est sympa de l'offre de kayes à l'oeuf
d'autruche l'oeuf d'autruche il faut pas
se casser direct parce que sinon tu te
pète la gueule
moi je serais super six non non non non
non non je t'explique tu peux regarder
un cd de fraises film et moi je parle et
mange pas je te le dis les mange pas
réussi à faire c'est bien tu veux faire
a bien failli c'est évident il est le
jean claude van damme de la tv
[Applaudissements]
moi aussi je te jure t là j'ai envie de
me taper en fait à gens que tu m'as
sauvé da
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'occupation du nord
non
[Musique]
cette fusillade a vu des gars en train
de se taper sur une musique comme ça il
en riant c'est pour ça jean-claude te
jure je suis tellement fan de toi et
franchement il pas beau gosse diouf est
un corps de ouf tancevova temps et un
lieu qui me cache avec toi tu fais
combien d'heures de sport par jour
ça dépend quand tu voyages tu as un
problème parce qu'il n'y a pas de salle
de sport je sais alors quand tu arrives
de voyages normalement il faut aller
directement lost and away et quand tu
fais ton packing tout voilà bagages et
tu vois le trouvera le bagage j'en
connais un très beau très beau fessier
très beau coup très light c'est un beau
travail à jouer au méchant tout ça et je
te jure jean chrétien le corps se fait
sur la tête de ma mère dans le corps que
je kifferais avoir surtout avec l'âge
c'est important la flexibilité la
couarde flexibilité
et habite maintenant d'amidou s'habitue
maintenant encore non tu m'invites c'est
pour sa place demain électro tout bon de
bien gros mots non nagées du bord on a
le gros bordel ça n'a jamais choqué
personne
ouais mais d'entrée aux études crois que
tu es venu avec un méga ouais j'suis pas
cyril 0 est offert et et c'est plus
qu'un tel but contre qui tu es là allez
jean claude jean claude tu sais quoi
on va faire une voiture de bataille un
full contact
c'est parti alors alors je crois je
m'élançais pas qu'ils mélangent
jean-claude que j'ai plus confiance en
toi comme moi ok c'est pareil pour moi
je dis waouh
[Musique]
ça a changé hollywood
[Rires]
bonjour pour l'offre de cahiers à les
attentions jean claude tu prends tu veux
je coupe le couple comme ça c'est vrai
je coupe je coupe je circoncis les
cartes gens que tu veux commencer tous
occidentaux de cheval la merci de la
carte la plus faible points à 9 dans la
gueule et jean-claude désignera
quelqu'un si c'est le plus faible
c'est pas possible
quand tu es bon tu es bon que ce quant à
dire à structure et à toi ou alors il
faut que tu sois en dessous mais pas au
dessus je serai derrière soit en dessous
ouais bon ok je peux prendre un car en
dessous si tu as un chroniqueur qui
mènera le cap d'agde c'est le 3g montrer
cela est scandaleux
jean claude a perdu jean claude qui pour
l'oeuvre de kayes c'est un tout petit a
faim voilà un petit tu sais rien du tout
c'est rien ça va faire sur tout c'est
ici des femmes et on débouche bien plus
haché pas qui tu veux lui tu veux lui sa
maman ça va être dur pour moi maintenant
à toi tu entends c'est mieux pour des
poteaux des petits oeufs alors benjamin
jeu la cassonade et basse et jean claude
ans les gens ne se rate est ici sur la
tête
non je peux pas faire ça
assez fier g t au sur le port sur le net
son temps et je m'excuse auquel poigne
ok ok ça devient bon il me kiffe là
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
gervais l'ozone je voudrais remercier
jean-claude van damme
je te jure t légende